on m'a lancé un défi on balance un
challenge on m'a dit monsieur greu on va
t'envoyer un ordinateur pour montrer à
quel point c'est important d'avoir une
machine quand on prend soin qu'on
nettoie correctement pour lui permettre
d'aller le plus loin possible en fait
c'est qui veut aller loin ménage sa
monture c'est la même chose avec votre
ordinateur alors moi je fais
utilisateurs de mac j'utilise un macbook
pro pour travailler pour faire des
vidéos mais montage des éditions fermé
miniature les éditer bien évidemment
lightroom photoshop je monte avec final
cut pro donc j'utilise un mac
donc quand on m'a proposé monsieur
grehan on va t'envoyer un mac tu va
tester ça mc qui n'a pas été nettoyé
depuis très longtemps ça mc qui a besoin
d'être entretenue et on va voir si tu
arrives à bosser dessus c'est tu arrives
à mettre en place des process et tu
arrives à l'utiliser correctement et si
toutefois sa passe pas on va proposer
une solution
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est donc aujourd'hui une vidéo qui
réalisé en partenariat avec cleanmymac
cleanmymac m'a envoyé ce colis se coller
qu'on va ouvrir ensemble et puis on va
essayer de relever le challenge
mc sos challenge on va donc essayer de
résoudre ensemble ce mac sos challenge à
aurélien agneray ditto faith de mac sos
challenge vous avez vu l'accent il a 5
royal
alors là une nouvelle quoique imam un
coq et à propos de l' in my mac l'idée a
effectivement cessé de pousser à venir
utiliser kinda imac et je pense que
c'est là la preuve par l'absurde on va
chercher à me démontrer qu'une machine
qui rament
globalement c'est pas possible donc si
on prend pas soin de cette machine est
bien ça pour faudra pas où lola sa sas a
vécu sa r&d la tronche du chargeur ou
lalalalalala macbook air celui-là il ya
quelques années déjà voir un petit peu
déjà à ce que ça dit fait voir ou au la
vache où j'ai eu des bureaux comme ça
mais quand on a un bureau comme ça on
n'aime pas sa machine un peu de
retouches photo marion va commencer
comme ça je suis une machine un peu
anciennes ça met un peu de temps c'est
normal poubelle près c'est un prendre
son temps pour avoir confiance on est
quand même sur une petite progression
hassaï south à saillé dans la photo
charles alors a tant fait voir cancun
note complété de copies comme andy cole
the scratch disque a full cool note
export disque libor because it's too big
to explore comment et renvoie exporté
faut s'armer de patience hommes c'est
quoi cette blague
on va essayer de se faire un petit peu
de montage ou la vache c'est
l'actionnaire ces espèces de challenge
parce que tu vois que tu veux faire un
truc tu veux ouvrir rien ne se passe et
c'est extrêmement frustrant et moi un
ordinateur qui rament sa monnaie sur les
nerfs à chaque fois parce que je sais
tout le travail que j'ai à faire à côté
je sais les e-mails la traiter je sais
les délégués à tenir pour publier parce
qu'une vidéo en plus une autre et quand
je vois que ça mais trois jours ne
serait ce qu'à vérifier hadopi premiere
pro je me dit claire on n'est pas au
bout de nos soucis là je n'ai même pas
ouvert 1
une vidéo dedans donc j'imagine même pas
le temps passé à monter et à exporter on
lis même pas la peine d'y penser
bon dentiste un peu couru d'avancé
désolé une erreur s'est produite c'est
quoi ce bazar
paige failed to open super tout se passe
bien tout va bien qu'est ce que c'est
que ce truc ça me met des plantages
saissac je faisais que ça mais c'est
quoi ces messages d'erreur là toutes les
deux secondes
pendant ce temps là le petit aurélien
attendait sagement que son ordinateur
arrête de ram et j'ai même pas ce qu'ils
restent en espace disque capacité
disponible 7j ya déjà 16 gigas apic tu
vas pas très loin a déjà le disque est
petit il est plein forcément ça [ __ ]
hélas hélas il ya plus rien à faire
c'est mort je déclare l'ordinateur avoir
arrêté de fonctionner à 21h58 je vais
remonter je vais me poser et demain
j'installe leurs solutions climat imac
et on va regarder comment on peut
réussir optimisé ça parce que le
problème ce n'est pas tant la machine à
les vieilles elle a fait son temps
certes mais c'est pas tant la machine
c'est un disque plein c'est un vrai
bazar dans les fichiers je crois que les
choses sont claires lieu ne récupérera
pas je crois que là-dessus qu'ils
mouillent mac vous avez raison sur le
fait qu'une machine de toute façon qui
est lente au bout d'un moment il faut
venir nettoyer faut venir l'entretenir
il faut venir voir ce qu'il passe pour
venir améliorer tous à améliorer le
process donc ce que j'ai fait ici
et bien comme vous le savez ici c'est
une vidéo qui est réalisé en partenariat
avec l'ina mbacké l'idée effectivement
est bien c'est de voir comment est-ce
que climat et mac peut venir vous aider
ici aujourd'hui
très concrètement donc je les ai
installés on va commencer par faire une
analyse intelligente pour venir regarder
un petit peu tous qui a analysé voyez je
peux venir voir ce que je vais analyser
notamment dans le système là par exemple
ancienne mise à jour version documents
fichiers xcode inutile on coche tout
parce que là je crois que vu le bazar
cas là dedans il va falloir faire un
tour complet du côté de la performance
également les applications bloquer les
éléments de script de maintenance vider
le cache dns
enfin bref voilà il ya quand même
beaucoup de choses qui vont être
vérifiées ici pour voir si on arrive à
lui rendre sa jeunesse d'antan et si
après ça devient plus utilisable ou si
ça continue comme ça
le scanner terminée voilà ce que nous
raconte le rapport il marque bon voilà
ce que j'ai trouvé toutes les tâches de
nettoyer des dernières hockey nettoyage
supprimer les contenus inutile 1,25 giga
protection ok aucune
détecté ça c'est plutôt bien et
performances accélérer votre système
trois tâches à exécuter allez on va se
faire exécuter puis on va regarder ce
qui nous dit alors nettoyage de vos
systèmes exécution des scripts de
maintenance vider le cache dns
libérerait dollar aucune menace
immédiate mais il vous recommande quand
même une analyse approfondie et on va
quand même lancé staff analyse
approfondie approfondie bonne nouvelle
aucune vulnérabilité potentielle était
détectée sur votre mac pensée
régulièrement faire une vérification ok
j'ai fait mon analyse intelligente
ok nettoyage du système je peut
optimiser mon système corriger d'autres
erreurs
les pièces jointes des mails les
corbeilles hockey les fichiers
malveillants ça s'est fait tout va bien
la confidentialité il va falloir tenir
regarde également ça et ensuite j'ai
tout l'optimisation g l'entretien fois
la vache tout ce que je peux faire je
peux venir d installer des applis faire
des mises à jour alors j'ai fait un tour
complet j'ai fait à peu près toutes les
analyses possibles et imaginables
analyse terminé donc là déjà g7 giga que
je peux venir dégager donc ça hop là ça
m'intéresse et g kwh affichée cache de
navigateurs 980 18 mégas ce n'est pas le
plus gros mais on doit quand même le
faire les téléchargements aussi les
fichiers cache donc là j'ai pas mal de
trucs déjà déjà je peux venir enlever
opaque et nettoyer
regardez g6 giga 39 à venir supprimés
avec tous ses fichiers d'ostal y en a
plein moi je sais pas vous mais c'est
vrai que dans mon bac je fais ça et
j'installe des programmes et je pense
jamais à les supprimer il traîne dans
nos dossiers de téléchargement pendant
longtemps et je supprime donc là on va
venir les virer vous disposez à présente
14 est disponible sur votre disque de
démarrage c'est déjà mieux
ensuite les pièces jointes j'ai regardé
j'ai vu globalement n'y avait pas de
problème la corbeille je peux venir
vider ma corbeille qu'est-ce que j'ai
dessiné par calcul de la corbeille fait
il n'y a pas de problème fichiers
malveillants on a vu qu'ils avaient pas
de soucis confidentialité
georges et des applications qui sont
autorisés à accéder à des choses
notamment photoshop ici au dossier
bureau dossiers documents sans vaseline
my mac hockey parallèle des stops ça
c'est un émulateur de windows je crois
ok pas de souci si ça m'ira sur chrome
joie également les cookies ça c'est
plutôt bien aussi mon histoire de
navigation les mots de passe ok ça me va
bien ça permet de savoir en randonnée
sur sa machine ça c'est intéressant je
peux venir optimisée des choses sur le
lancement
les agents d'ouverture microsoft auto
apdeq est activée j'ai pas besoin de
tout ça là entretien tâche libéré de la
ram libérer l'espace purge abl
regardez on se fait un petit nettoyage
là c'est marrant parce qu'effectivement
cleanmymac mamba cette machine
ram et il m'en rends compte mais ça
permet de se rendre compte l'effectif
manque on a besoin des fois de venir
voler ce petit travail libéré de la ram
libérer l'espace purge a passé des
choses auxquelles je ne pense pas mais
vraiment pas et je vais regarder je
l'installé sur mon mac et je verrai ce
que ça dit après des installeurs bon les
a pas d installer il y en a j'ai des
programmes qui sont trop gros je peux
les lire et mettre à jour au keynote
morales que les 26 mise à jour
importante net des programmes jour il ya
un truc qui est vachement intéressant
partie télescope ça me permet de voir où
sont les datas les plus importants le
voit par exemple comment dossier
utilisateur
là où user g73 giga lan je me dis c'est
quoi ces 73 giga c'est d'un laptop je
vote des stocks donc sur le bureau j'ai
38 giga sur le bureau attendait c'est
quoi cette histoire là j'ai un espèce de
fichiers c'est un émulateur de windows
qui me fait à lui seul 12 giga fait dans
mon des stops
regardez regardez tout ce que j'ai là
sur le bureau chez des fichiers en
doublon cd vidéo donc tout ça je peux
venir supprimer j'ai des enregistrements
et ça c'est intéressant temps mais
vraiment d'avoir une vue d'ensemble de
ce qui se passe dans mon ordinateur et
devenir tout nettoyer très facilement
avec cette solution là et c'est ce que
ça me permet de découvrir
et bien c'est une façon tout en un pour
venir supprimer les fichiers
malveillants pour voir sinon système
fonctionne mal pour venir vider le dise
pour nettoyer des espaces j'ai tout en
un seul et même endroit c'est
intéressant c'est intuitif globalement
je connaissais pas cette solution ce
challenge m'a permis effectivement de
m'en rendre compte de la découvrir et je
vous dis ça en toute transparence
là je vais te virer 37 gia c'est quand
même pas mal je vois tous les fichiers
sur l'ordinateur je peux également les
triées par taille donc là je vais en
espèces de 10 aux de windows disent donc
c'est sûr les installe à regarder l'âge
en installant corps qui me reste de 5
gigas donc je peux venir
cliquez dessus je peux venir supprimés
je redis j'ai encore tout plein de
vidéos complètement un peu bullshit qui
me qui me prennent de la place et que je
vais supprimer 50 gigas de supprimer paf
autre truc qui est intéressant je
remonte rapidement lorsque vous êtes
dans le système sait les binaires
universels alors on vous explique depuis
qu'apple a commencé à fabriquer ces
puces m1 et bien les développeurs
doivent pour avoir la compatibilité
entre les mac intel et les mac apple
silicone m deux versions du code dans
leur application nous ici j'ai des
versions et bien qu ils me servent
strictement à rien donc je peux cliquer
ici et je supprime je nettoie en plus
812 méga supplémentaire donc ça c'est
pareil c'est bien ça
optimisation que je ne connaissais pas
et il ya un autre truc qui est
intéressant voire c'est dans le
désinstalleur pour les applications
yahoo fait un tri par taille pour
regarder ce qu'est le plus gros voyez
par exemple que j'ai à l'installateur de
mac os mort avait qui est installée là
qui fait si giga dont je n'ai pas besoin
et que je peux dire d installer je
supprime je vais gagner si j y ai de
plus donc voyez en fait que là ce qui
est super intéressant est ce que je vois
déjà lorsque je fais mon cleanmymac g
optimiser mon ordinateur j'ai nettoyé le
bureau donc déjà c'est quand même un
vrai confort
j'ai supprimé des choses en trop tu
content d'avoir relevé ce challenge
parce qu en étant utilisateur moi-même
de max et des choses que je ne voyais
pas nécessairement de cette manière là
merci cleanmymac de m'avoir envoyé ce
challenge j'ai pu participer
je pense que je vais relever le
challenge pour venir nettoyer son mac je
regarderai également sur mon mac qui
planquaient juste là bas j'ai serré je
vais regarder je vais nettoyer je pense
que je vais gagner de la place ça c'est
intéressant ça lui permettra d'aller
plus loin donc je vous invite vous à
venir essayer à venir installer la
version gratuite une version d'essai de
cleanmymac d'amis les liens en bas dans
la description essayé télécharger
regarder ce qu'il en est et si ça vous
intéresse
aller plus loin pour revenir à
entretenir vos mac dans les meilleures
conditions a vous de me dire vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire est
ce que vous avez renard qu'est ce que
vous pensez que votre mac a besoin
d'être entretenue amélioré pour aller
plus vite
marc guillemot bien évidemment tout ça
en bas en commentaire et quant à nous on
se retrouve bientôt pour continuer bien
évidemment à parler avec 10,6 à des
bisous beaucoup d'amour pour les soldes
ou à bientôt ciao